dès le début de cette crise les artistes
les auteurs compositeurs nous ont émus
avec leur leurs propositions avec des
événements très personnel très intimiste
et michel rivard n'échappe pas ça il a
eu la bonne idée de partager sur
facebook une chanson presque tous les
jours depuis le début il est avec nous
on a fait une perle dont les liens
facebook c'est pourquoi michel rivard
bonsoir merci d'être là on va forcément
ils meurent en a fait une pause plus
longue pour permettre de faire
concurrence
mais comment il vous est venue l'idée de
cette histoire là à changer votre regard
sur le monde
comme la plupart de mes camarades on a
perdu du jour au lendemain tous nos
spectacles tous nos engagements toutes
nos tournées toutes nos émissions télé
et puis moi c'est plus fort que moi j'ai
besoin de ce lien là avec le public
alors je me suis dit pourquoi pas
proposer quotidiennement un rendez vous
sur facebook dans l'intimité à 20 heures
après nous avoir parlé de l'être sur
facebook ça soit c'est pas toujours
c'est pas toujours à la même heure
jeanjean j'en fais une par jour et les
gens je le fais pas en direct
je le fais en différé hockey et les gens
sur michel rivard pages officielles
peuvent chaque jour avoir soin de
nouvelles chansons écrites le jour même
ou alors une chanson du répertoire et le
regard que vous portez sur nous sur
notre réaction sauf par rapport à voir
du quotidien de la vie quotidienne des
gens ces appels à la solidarité on le
vit hier monsieur legault faire appel
aux bénévoles en santé québécois suivent
on a besoin de cette communication là
qu'est ce que tu as écouté deux secondes
je tousse dans mon coude et mes mains
sont au programme d'un camé médecin
écoutez comme tout le monde on se sent
on se sent tous dans le même bateau
c'est paradoxal mais cette maladie
épouvantable nous fait nous sentir
ensemble g g avec ses petites capsules
un lien très très privilégié avec le
public qui m'écrit on compare nos
aux expériences et c'est vraiment pour
moi un bon mais j'espère que pour les
gens que que j'atteins se lit aussi oui
parce qu'on se sent on reçoit tellement
le corps et l on fait de l'information
des fois c'est des mauvaises nouvelles
est un acte aussi déprimant mais en même
temps c'est laid ce sont les faits la
transparence puis on sait que la
communication est la grande gagnante
d'information dans cette histoire là on
le voit le goal de communication la
science et la science oui on est en
effet je faisais aujourd'hui je me
rapidement je vous dis que me faisait la
remarque si on peut garder cette
confiance l'auront en la science envers
les scientifiques
quand tout ça sera du passé notre combat
pour l'écologie pourrait pour sauver la
planète
on devrait se souvenir à quel point ce
qui a des liens scientifiques sur thème
porteur que des gens qui font le lion le
bouc pas beaucoup fait dans nos
émissions le lien entre l'écologie et ce
qui se passe actuellement est la force
des musiques j'ai le coup parce que chez
vous avez déjà donné un concert
symphonique avec le west ham puis
monsieur nagano my phone arnaud si elle
est ce matin vous allez me dire la force
de la musique je vous lis été dit de
tout temps nous avons pu observer
comment la musique s'avère en compagnie
acidu est fidèle à chaque étape de la
vie de l'enfance à l'âge adulte en
période de tragédies d'amour de joie de
solitude de réflexion ou de célébrations
tous ceux et celles les mamans comme si
vous montre que c'est très beau à
trimbach c'est tellement vrai qu'est ce
que la musique la force des musiques
pour vous et des mots dans les temps
difficiles la force la musique la force
de la poésie la force de l'or ouais la
force de l'art on a en une communauté
artistique au québec absolument
extraordinaire et je crois que nous
pouvons mettre la main à la pâte de la
façon en faisant ce qu'on sait faire le
mieux
qui est qui était de faire pas
nécessairement révélé jean louis les
faire rêver mais en même temps leur dire
exactement ce qui se passe ne pop ne pas
se cacher la situation mais ne pas non
plus abdiquer tout simplement en
continuant à écouter à lire à regarder
c'est très important
j'ai trouvé là de la fin de la phrase
maïs on dit donc à midi que partagent
l'amour de la musique constate qu'elle
représente la forme la plus pure de
l'esprit humain
de ce qu'il représentait de ce qu'il a à
offrir oui d'accord
la musique est la forme la plus pure
malheureusement moi je mets des paroles
ça vient gâcher la sauce succès mais
c'est le danger posé la question à la
minute joli tout à l'heure j'ai demandé
puis les entreprises culturelles font
elles partie de votre plan de sauvetage
aujourd'hui elle a dit détails lundi
alors oui j'ai on a hâte de savoir ce qu
il faudrait bien que c'est les deux on
vous dit un grand merci au nom de tous
ceux de tous vos fans depuis tant
d'années mais encore pendant ces moments
de confinement on voulait mais c'est
justement surpasser la chanson sur le
confinement
vous allez nous et c'est sur cela c'est
la chanson du 22 mars
les paroles ont été écrites en
collaboration avec ma blonde fdl 3 et ça
s'appelle en fait y'a pas de sucre à
l'ailé
[Rires]
on attendait bien oui
[Musique]
confiné dans la prison du monopoly
convaincre les garçons que c'est le fun
le marché s'y glisser sur certains
montent et les échelles usées 40 kgs on
a dessiné des arcs en ciel
on est des millions à jouer à cacher
entre la chambre le salon puis l'écran
de la tablette en classe par couleur nos
tiroirs à bobette
on joue les globe trotteurs dans mon
livre de recettes
on travaille de la maison en gérant nos
enfants on réalise que le problème c'est
pour toujours le seigneur on est des
millions à jouer à cacher entre la
chambre salon puis l'écran de la
tablette on annule nos sorties nos cours
de danse en ligne mais ont fini par
trouver des cours de danse en lait on
épuise la réserve de téléséries et on
trouve du charme aux reprises de skippy
on est des millions à jouer à cache est
entre la chambre le salon puis l'écrin
la tablette
un petit léger bridge instrumental ici
pour vous permettre d'aller laver vos
mains allez-y vous avez stage vous
atteint
[Musique]
ce nageur vous après essuyé des on
reprend en hâte la tribu d'or sur la
mélodie du bonheur bien mon trésor ont
rejoué ou docteur aussi dans neuf mois
le gros lot marc moutout marmont on
l'appellera tartelettes ou gâteau on
l'appellera horatio vers d'oreille sur
un album éventuellement puis s'en va et
je suis story
michel merci on vous embrasse merci